[Musique]
aujourd'hui une seconde recette à base
de champignons dans la première émission
de cette série nous avions mis des
champignons en conserve et aujourd'hui
nous allons faire des galettes de cèpes
au foie gras aux fumées de vieux ceps et
cela promet ah oui c'est une recette de
francis garcia nous le remercions
beaucoup nous abandonner alors la frappe
aussi bien que lui sort c'est sûr on va
essayer alors il faut d'abord un bon
bouillon de légumes un bouillon avec
troisième mais il ne faut pas installer
alors là on l'a fait on a mis du jarret
de veau du jarret de boeuf et le
croustillant de portes et voilà le vous
appelez la croustade aux pommes l'os les
côtés les eaux des côtes
alors va mettre deux louches de bouillon
non salées et mona sahlin le salaire des
villes parce qu'en réduisant plus il se
réduit plus le garçon si les regards de
son sel et donc on va les mettre en
valeur ce bouillon bon dans ce bouillon
on va y mettre un verre de porto
oui que voici qu'à mettre le verre de
porto et vous
et en plus on prend un vieux ceps
beaucoup plus dur que celui ci mais là
on en a pas c'est pour ça que francine
en ciel qui mieux mieux qu'hier nous
alors on va mettre ce sel on va le
mettre dans ce bouillon avec le porto et
on va y mettre
en plus c'est cette coupe est ce là où
baissent alors normalement il faut les
aimiez les mrc petit à petit et on va le
mettre pour ça a trop fait pas trop
faire là ça passe par dessus la jambe à
la layan assad appartient y en a assez
il faut laisser réduire
une bonne heure orwell au niveau honneur
en instant on va préparer les gagnent
les galettes
alors vous allez nous montrer comme on
les aime dans les galettes c'est très
facile il faut du blanc de poulet de la
crème fraîche un verre de porto décès
pts
2 échalotes ici qu'on a finalement
inversé du persil du foie gras bien sûr
et des blancs d'oeuf pour le foie pour
préciser tout de suite un foie de canard
c'est un poids de la neige qu'est ce
qu'on va faire maintenant dans preniez
alors maintenant on va prendre le bain
de poulet et on va lâcher ici parce
qu'il faut qu'ils soient broyés très
faim alors là on a mis un petit couteau
et ça va très bien ça peut être fait au
mixeur mais abel en longueur à
l'ancienne avec la grille la plus fine
du havre oui la plus fine
voilà on met le blanc de poulet ici sera
table voilà on le bel âge on prend la
place ensuite qu est-ce qu on ajoute les
blancs d'oeuf et blanche de m le journal
20 alors je m'émeus blanc là combien aux
trois pour cette qualité de jeu blanc on
avait une belle elle puis quelques
broutilles hoodwink de wembley alors
nous avons m je me trompais oui voilà le
blanc le blanc s'impose non là je pense
qu'il ya assez de blancs peuple quantité
oui très bien ce qui va beaucoup de
poulet qu'est ce qu'un de la tromperait
après on ajoute la crème fraîche
oui alors la crème fraîche on va
remettre deux bonne cuillère oui de
crème fraîche sa part est drôle mais si
je vous assure excellent donc ensuite on
va mettre le verre de porto
oui là et puis réveillé puis le principe
alara maghraoua nous allons mettre le
foie gras que nous allons couper ses du
foie seraient vos fruits
non car oui frais toute assez serait
tout à fait serez alors voilà on va la
mettre comme ça une belle tranche de
belles tranches moi je vais te couper en
petits morceaux j'ai parlé couteau qui
coupe le moteur ne pas dire si cet
endroit oui il m'arrive n'est pas là
pour l'elysée à maïté voilà oui mais là
ça va c'est tellement entendant que ça
va se noyer
et puis vous allez nie les charges et où
ça un peu de serrer un peu de pouvoir
mais très peu parce que je n'en ai pas
parce que le poulet et ça n'est pas
même le tout jeune armée pas bon mais
pas de sel bon alors of brise tout ceci
l'a rapidement pour que la main ne
chauffe pas le voir fondre est
exactement il faut que ça fasse une
crème glacée molette voilà est assez
onctueux saint laurent va bien malaxer
de tous la pâte est prête pour maïté si
je comprends bien deux blancs 2 3 blancs
de beaucoup de crème peu de crème
beaucoup de portes ou peu de porto sait
plus quoi faire le tounoi ça c'est par
rapport aux poulets qu'on y met oui par
rapport aux 2,1 grosseur des oeufs alors
on fait au coup d'oeil bon génie de
jaune d'oeuf de la lande
j'en ai mis trois parce que je trouvais
ça se faisait il faut on voit il faut
que la pâte soit bien joli il faut
qualifier mais il faut pas trop la revue
et quand même faut pas que ça tourne
c'est la rentrée nous vient la
consistance voilà très bien et puis on
va attaquer les scènes on va attaquer
mais voilà ça nous mettons de côté août
je vous donne de quoi vous essuyez les
mains parce que vous aimez en juillet
challenge m en remettre à la pointe sur
le feu avec de l'huile
voilà la poêle à chauffer et on va
couper les scènes alors voir vos
recettes
les vrais cep des bancs simples voisins
ou amis de vieux ceps dans le fumé
d'arleux fume
là nous avons des jolies scènes que nous
allions en petite pompe est assez
finement
oui parce que vous allez voir pourquoi
je me laisse même temps les sur quatre
est là alors on va le mettre
voyez cela il est magnifique et les
jolies on va le mettre dans notre droit
la réforme ça va ça va truc oui mais
télé 7 vous allez laisser revenir comme
étant très sonore minute cinq minutes
présentant pas longtemps parce qu'ils
sont coupés très sain et ensuite vous
ajoutez un tout brille peu d'échalotes
un tout petit peu mais pas beaucoup me
faut quinze fois très près très très
finement haché
lorsqu'il faut pas qu'on la trouve mans
on va manger la galette ans la normale
est complètement fondu lié à maintenant
soupçon de goût mais cette eau dans la
salle et prendre un café quand même oui
il faut attendre que les cèpes soir
c'est cuit parce que l'échalote ils sont
pas qu'elle ramènera que l'heure est à
la fête
après voilà
vous l'avez vous prépare les chaînes sur
le chemin du gordo la légère la
meilleure bière bien fine
oui voilà l'échalas merci on va mettre
tout ça ensemble
voilà et c'est enfin gaulin quand elle
aura fondu quand elle rentrait bercy que
j'oserais perçu aussi mais seulement du
persil dû verser du sable surtout parlez
surtout pas d'ailleurs alors on met le
persil bien dessus bien assez et on
laisse mijoter intelligente un tout
petit peu et pendant ce temps on va
préparer quoi les ramequins dire albert
canada alors je voulais mais sur la
planche
plus loin un on va prendre ses râles au
caire il faut libérer et pourquoi
et pour que ça se démoule parce qu'on va
des moules et après alors voyez avec les
doigts ya pas de serait maintenant c'est
la meilleure manière d'aider comme je
veux un contournement mais confère des
droits alors avec edouard baer pendant
sa vie quand on fait la cuisine et hier
on a le robinet ça cool
ouais voilà alors on met ça non on
essaie ramequins sur place oui pendant
ce temps on va sortir nos seniors qui
fait prendre à commencer à mettre notre
crème vous me passez la crème là ça
votre pâte votre balle autres pattes de
poulet va on va mettre cette pâte
on va mettre une couche de pâte comme
ceux ci dans l'eau durant dans le fond
des vainqueurs et puis arrive doit on va
la laisser un petit peu à faire tourner
pour qu'il y en ait un peu sur le vo sur
l'eau sus le quotidien sur le côté du
revers
on va tapisser le ramequin avec voilà
c'est bien vous me sauver en très bien
alors là on va recommencer encore la
même opération
sa verve et le doit un petit peu
préservé à la main légère et délicate
n'est ce pas une super lourdes c'est
pour ça voilà voilà la c2a le quinson on
va mettre ça de côté
repas dans l'os est très bien regarder
les super 7
ils sont magnifiques voiliers la
persillade l'échalote
on ne la voit pratiquement plus alors on
va retapisser le fort bien la règle
c'est bien dit
seulement que nous voyons comment vous
faites la manière assez là viendra c'est
d'abord beaucoup et je vous assure et
c'est un régal
c'est très léger c'est pas lourd pour qu
à les gérer
c'est extra voilà et on va finir on va
leur laisser mes potes on va finir de
remettre on va couvrir avec un mois
notre pattes de poulet voilà la mairie
de chalabre là et elle rend cuisant
savent adoré ça va être accordée rôle là
et puis ces permis de saison ça parce
que bon avec la conserve
on veut faire ça n'importe quoi toute
l'année on peut faire ça parce que la
sauce on peut la mettre au congélateur
pas faire d' avance oui et on peut faire
ça m'importe commun et on peut
accommoder ça avec ce qu'on veut la vie
renaît conséquent modulation c'est le
sommet de l'osce avait regardé de dire
quand je regardais le regarder comme il
est beau mais il faut encore le lycée
réduire encore un peu
il faut qu'il soit encore en servent
presque arwing maïté 6 ramequins
qu'est ce qu'on en scène on va le faire
cuire comment alors on va les mettre
dans un plat qui va au four avec de
l'eau dedans et bastin baril selon
robert marie on va les mettre là et on
va les mettre à four chaud whishaw quand
même oui on va les mettre
voilà faire qu'on a prêché au fait le
four le four a bien choisi les métriques
au dos oui vous allez laisser à peu près
combien du canada saleh dans des fours
dix minutes un quart d'heure ne vous
regardez jusqu'à ce qu'ils soient bien
dorés sur le dessus c'est la couleur qui
c'est la couleur qui commande bien dorés
retraites ils sont dorés c'est cuit
parce que ce tout est cuit dedans oui
alors il faut qu'il soit pris le blog
bien doré très bon là c'est tout nos
galettes 5,8 alors ils ont affaire on va
les moules et allez-y attention ne pas
vous brûler notre être et sans espère
mois va faire de bêtises du four au sol
et vous savez salir petit comme ça mais
c'est très nourrissants et cet extrait
or il
voilà voilà alors maintenant qu'est ce
conseil vous les arrose il faut aller
chercher notre amour et notre fumée qui
est vrai mais regardez-moi ça c'est les
réduit là qu'est ce que vous y ajoutez
un rien de crème ou parce que ma vie oui
les liens de crem la soupe sors moi
j'appelle ça c'est comme ça c'est comme
ça et on va remettre ça donne une jolie
petite couleur parce qu'il faut pas que
ce accusé la crème fraîche et bien sûr
c'est juste d'aller applaudir la poésie
dévoile pour la ranger et sané gâte rien
chose voilà
et alors nous allons verser dessus notre
petite sauce il faut le manger tout soit
willy brûlant et on va mettre nos cette
voie là par côté et je vous assure c'est
comme on dit chez nous c'est pas
dégueulasse et une fois plus envie dire
la part ça on en perd la teigne at on
des bâtisses quoi voilà alors là se
mélangeaient cep de porte ou de roissy
et bien je vous souhaite un très bon
appétit voilà et on se donne rendez vous
là pour la prochaine version lite et la
prochaine émission est bien ce seront je
crois si on est d'accord la prochaine
les magrets de canard fourré aux 7es au
nôtre permettre froid gras qui est extra
le foie gras des landes à bien sans
pouvoir
[Musique]